here's the first thing I want to point
out you notice in this particular case I
went to cosmos right so I can get that
in fact I could do this to science I'm
if I wanted to how would I do it we're
not going to go ahead and solve all the
way but how would I do it what could I
do differently okay I've got sine X and
cos x both there and I chose that Buddha
cross - I know right I can just take our
cross cause if I want to I can say sine
x equals minus because X and I can say
by definition cosine is what sorry
that's a Sun in terms of science it's
the compliment right which is PI on to
minus X yeah ah but look what kind of
function is sine what kind of symmetry
does it have it's an odd function right
so therefore in this place I would write
ok now you should see without me even
finishing it is above the symmetry so
this way of approaching the solution
look at this line versus this one do you
see how symmetrical they are no I could
go ahead and I can find a solution I
could do that but right at the beginning
you suggested to me this that I can do
by auxilary angry Jews fine tuning okay
so how am I do this I'm trying to
confirm for myself whether I have the
right solution or not I know it could be
really really rigorous at it but covers
your memory what's the amplitude of my G
function
to the square root 2 it's a sweater
dollar you know you see what you're
being accomplished it's wrong okay
listen to sign a pretty sure sign will
be easier
what shift is going to be involved what
will my alpha what will my talk to the
Rangel be pretty sure will be plus
partly now if you like you can go
through all of the steps to continue
something that is the case okay
what would I do here well I'm just
trying to solve for a baby with zero so
I'm gonna take out this guy I used to
bite through food what's the solution to
this
oh it's just
oh no it's not this is not the channel
solution beside its plus what this one
to the end all sine inverse of 0 which
is 0 which is 0 right
so now what do i do i say x equals 4
okay
so what just happened we read through
one path we took which of cosine we said
let's to put all in the cosines whose
general solution what would have to be a
dead end
weird but okay and there's no way to
argue with the algebra you take the part
that's left and this is what remains you
can use on doing angle and you can
confirm it right you can confirm it
again
right by doing it this way right you can
say x equals and pi plus etc and you can
do your audit even cases from this don't
be surprised if one of the branches the
end up doing as their solutions okay
because again this is huge symmetry to
the way why is their solution I think
about it is this way the whole idea of
I'm doing this and saying no there's two
there's two positives is to say you
always getting a pair of solutions pair
solutions pair solutions but when you
come back to what you're actually
solving right and what the like what
this turns into we know it's actual
shape is closer to sign when you
consider it within that domain all right
so if we you're not going to get those
pairs of solutions you're only gonna get
one every time in fact let's just do it
this way shall we okay what are we
saying we're looking for sine X plus cos
x okay let's just do a new one shall we
so I'm looking for sine X plus can you
guys see it it's a visible cos x there
it is okay know what I'm suggesting is
my solutions are my takeaway
so what do you think that request
solution me I think the first solution
will be negative plan for for N equals
zero yeah so I'm gonna go x equals
negative PI on four BAM there's my first
one now you have a look have a look
where does the next one come up and it
comes up pi radians later what's pi take
we're planful but you can work it out
it's 3/4 pi right so 3 PI on full BAM oh
yeah do you need me to do another one
like how many would we like the next
one's 7 PI on 404 ok I'm gonna stop now
so you can see what you're getting
you're lucky this just had some
solutions it's like you know then it
correspond to anything you I've nailed
every single one okay now you've got
some good time to get back into 1m I
only got you started I'm gonna issue a
few more questions yeah but this
actually I mean questions like this
they're already sort of towards that end
of what they have to say when you do
generous there's no question ok you can
see that's a bit of a curveball right
questions pretty straightforward
that's not straight forward roll you'll
be doing believe how many students get
to this line something we were wrong and
then we somehow magically come up with
solution they come from this and that's
what we know ok someone doesn't
understand what this